yo what's up guys it's marcus brownlee
here from mkbhd
and welcome to another hd video and this
one is going to be the tech channel of
the week episode number six and this uh
youtube user is computer help guy one
and uh of course his link will be in the
description
uh so computer help guy one also known
as lorner
um is actually from scotland and what he
does is pretty much a lot of uh tutorial
videos
and uh the the videos he has here on his
youtube channel are actually really
really extensive i'm extensive and i'm
going to give you pretty much a full
tour of his youtube channel right now
so first of all his youtube layout is
actually a yt layouts layout i used to
use this layout in the earlier days of
my channel before i took a different one
and edited it to be my own
as we scroll down a bit here you'll see
he has 417 subscribers we can get him up
to 500 guys
and um
right now if we go down here uh to the
left-hand side you can see uh you can
follow him on twitter and i'll post his
twitter and flickr photo stream in the
description now you may or may not know
that i posted a link to the high
resolution photos of the jello skins
installation in the description of the
jealous skins video so i do have a
flickr photo stream and uh so does
lorner here computerhealthguy1
he's also approaching uh 20 000 channel
views and also other things about him
he's from scotland which i'm assuming is
part of the uk
and that's why he has honors for uh
directors in the united kingdom
and as we scroll down a bit here this is
why i like his youtube channel he has
194 videos 194 tutorials software videos
request videos and they're all pretty
well made videos and he uses um i'm
pretty sure camtasia studio 6 as his
screen recorder
um
so yeah having 194 tech related videos
on his youtube channel almost as much as
me he really gets his content out there
he has a lot of helpful information
there
actually if we scroll back up his latest
video was about using a firefox add-on
called stylish uh to turn your youtube
channel or your google homepage uh to be
black
or whatever theme you want it to be
i'm gonna go ahead and click on his most
viewed videos section here because he
actually has a number of windows 7
videos that he's been putting up in the
past five six months in fact even his
most viewed video uh is in the past two
weeks and he's been doing videos on on
his windows 7 beta build and release
candidate over the past couple of weeks
and it's really been as smooth as
anything
as smooth as my windows vista tutorials
and stuff like that so really having 194
videos i think is the strength of this
channel uh that he's answered a lot of
questions already he's done request
videos
uh and that's how he has so many
subscribers and i'm sure we can get him
to 500 guys
also if we scroll down a little bit here
you'll see he has a few playlists one of
them is called dual booting which
probably means he's been using more than
one operating system uh not just
sticking to the windows 7 beta build the
whole time and he has a three video
series about windows 7 tips and
obviously not a lot of people are one
running windows 7 at the moment but i'm
sure when windows 7 is released in its
full version that's going to be a very
popular playlist as well as other
windows 7 videos
so thanks for watching this tech channel
of the week number six i appreciate uh
all the entries and all the people who
have been making great videos who have
subscribed to me i'm subscribed to him
he has subscribed to me and um he does
you know rate my videos five stars and
comments and all that and i'm really i
really appreciate him uh being a part of
this community uh so your best chance of
becoming the next tech channel of the
week is obviously being a subscriber and
uh producing quality tech videos that
deserve a look at and i'm just showing
my audience uh things they might like to
check out if they want to go check out
your youtube channel that link will be
in the description of your tech channel
of the week video
so anyway thanks for watching guys go
ahead and check out computer help guy
one and uh thanks for watching this
software video i'm alternating back and
forth between software and hardware here
and that's basically it thanks for
watching guys peace